Speaker 1: And speaking of that,
I think that was an unintended and
unintended segway. The Republican Party
is also in a bad boat. Mike Lindell,
Kari Lake did this very off the wall interview
with Steve Bannon. They were at the the Republican
winter meeting where they reelected Ronna Romney
McDaniel to be chairperson of the Republican
National Committee, the National Committee. She's
once again the chair of. And this came to great
consternation for the the Mypillow goof who wanted
he he was in the running along with a lawyer out
of San Francisco, Maine, named Harmeet Dhillon,
and they both lost two to run a Romney McDaniel.
She she lost the Romney because Donald Trump
didn't like it. But I know I'm just that PETTY I'm
going to continue to Colorado. Romney. MCDANIEL
But this this clip that I'm going to play for
you of the Bannon interviewing both Carrie Lake
and Mike Lindell, sitting side by side is just
bizarre. And it's not bizarre for the fact that
the background is actually more blurry than Carrie
Lake's face usually is. It's bizarre because
they're doing the thing that I've been talking
about very recently, but also for months, that the
rhetoric surrounding not having a country anymore,
the rhetoric surrounding our republic being just
a failed state, the rhetoric surrounding us losing
our sovereignty is being whipped up into a frenzy
by these particular fringe clowns. Watch this.
Speaker 2: Ron Ronna. Ronna McDaniel has not
been there for three days. Ronna McDaniel has
not pulled you aside and said, Let's have a cup
of coffee and spend 5 minutes together. Have
you guys spent time with each other one on one?
Speaker 5: No, we have an unfortunate. And you
know what? I do want to reach out to her because
here's what's going on. And I know that this
might not be the popular view. Ronna want it for.
Speaker 2: Full stop paying for stop. You should.
You shouldn't have to. You shouldn't have to reach
out to Ronna McDaniel. You're the frickin governor
of Arizona. Use one. An incredibly tough race
because you stood for policies that MAGA stands
for. She should be blown your phone up every
day. Can I get 5 minutes? This is outrageous.
Speaker 5: But here's what I'm willing to
do. I'm willing to meet with her and say,
let's move forward, because this next election,
if we do not get President Donald Trump back in
the White House, I don't know how much longer
we can last. I think our republic is in peril.
I will do everything in my power if that means I
can walk across the country, whatever it means.
I want to get President Trump, my friend.
Speaker 2: But hang on, hang on, hang on. If
we don't get you in Arizona, if
we don't get you in Arizona now,
I'm not sure we have sovereignty.
Speaker 1: All of that is alarming because,
one, they're just leaning in to the conspiracy
theory that Kerry Lake won the election. You
shouldn't have to wait for Ron and Ron McDaniel
to call you. You're the governor of Arizona.
It's news to the rest of the country.
Steve Bannon. Steve Bannon, who has has his hands
in the attempted coup in Brazil. Steve Bannon,
who had his hand deeply in to the insurrection at
the United States Capitol on January six, 2021.
The attempted overthrow of the United States
government, partly many believe, orchestrated,
planned and executed by Steve Bannon and his
colleagues. And here he is again trying to whip
up the base by using language like this. And
she doesn't jettison it. She doesn't swatted
away. She embraces it. This next election if we
don't get Donald Trump back in the White House,
I don't know how much longer we can last.
I think our republic is in peril, she says.
That is strong language that whips clowns
like David Pap. The guy who was talking
about the the Tree of Liberty needed watered
by the blood of patriots is what would follow.
It's those types of people who have
violent tendencies, who have a proclivity
to to radicalism. They're going to
be animated by language like this.
And he shuts her down on the Trump thing. He says,
No, no, no. If we don't get you in Arizona now,
I'm not sure we're going to have sovereignty.
All of this is problematic and all of this
should should animate you. To want to make a
difference in this upcoming election. Look,
I know it seems like, oh, we just got through
the midterms. 2024 is too far away to really
worry about that. It is not. You need to talk to
your friends, to your neighbors, to your family,
to your coworkers. Health, to the dude you sit
next to at the bus stop and talk to them about
this type of thing. Because if we can animate one
person each and they can animate one person, we
can overwhelm Republicans at the polls to ensure
that we don't lose our sovereignty, that we don't
lose our republic, that it absolutely is in peril,
but not for the reasons that Cory Lake says.
Once again, I'm Jessy Dallimore. Thank you for
joining me. You can follow me on twitter. I am
at dallimore there and twitter and instagram
and tik tok. I'm on youtube dallimore daily
or just search my stupid name. You'll find
me there. I'd love to have you subscribe and
be a regular watcher of my mouth that flaps
in my face that gets read when I get angry.
Anyway, I'll see you next time. Thanks a lot.